unser rk ii wert steigt damit auf 99,9
und ist weiterhin mit abstand der
höchste in ganz deutschland täglich neue
hiobsbotschaften haben im krisenmodus
mobile teams fahren durch die stadt
testen bürger in quarantäne
gleichzeitig forschen 160 mitarbeiter
vom gesundheitsamt nach kontaktpersonen
versuchen infektionswege einzugrenzen
auslöser für die korona explosion in
hamm sind private feiern rund um eine
türkische hochzeit unter anderem in
dieser halle die kommune beklagt später
probleme beim nachverfolgen der gäste
ergebnis letzte woche über 200
infizierte und 2500 menschen in
quarantäne
eine stadt leidet unter der
rücksichtslosigkeit einzelner wenn man
nur 150 statt und geht dann mit drei
beziehungen nach neu delhi
dann ist das her schon ein bisschen
übertrieben
man sollte nicht so denken das können
sie jeden treffen wir haben alle ältere
menschen so werden alle oma opa zu
wollen dass sie gesund bleiben
ich sage ich hätte auch gerne große
geburtstagsparty schon gefeiert und habe
darauf verzichtet und ich finde jeder
egal wer sollte darauf rücksicht nehmen
dass man sowas vielleicht im moment
unterlässt oberster krisenmanager ist
oberbürgermeister hunsteger-petermann
corona vermasselt ihn vergangene woche
den wahlkampf ein duell mit dem
herausforderer findet noch stadt alle
weiteren wahlkampftermine sind wegen
corona gestrichen
mit strengeren regeln will er verhindern
dass sich so ein desaster ausgelöst
durch private feiern mit vielen gästen
wiederholt zwischen 25 und 50 müssen die
feiern bei uns angezeigt werden zwischen
50 und 150 müssen sie uns zur
genehmigung vorgelegt werden und wir
gucken uns jeden einzelnen antrag sehr
genau an
also im 23 geburtstag zum beispiel wenn
wir nicht genehmigen das ist kein
herausragender anlass
münchen auch ein corona hotspot die
stadt hatte zeitweise den kritischen
wert von 50 neuinfektionen pro 100000
einwohner überschritten
seit vergangener woche gilt deshalb in
der innenstadt masken pflicht auch
draußen
für uns kommt ganz überrascht aber gut
sein muss
andere nehmen es mit der masken pflicht
nicht so ernst warum seniorentag weil
ich im moment nicht bedrängt bin und ich
kenne man näheren bekanntenkreis
kennenlernen corona krankenhaus von
daher ist es für mich nicht so klein
wahrscheinlich wird es seinen sinn haben
wer ohne maske erwischt wird muss mit
einem bußgeld von 250 euro rechnen
laut münchner polizei aber halten sich
die meisten an die neuen regeln auch
beim bummel auf dem viktualienmarkt
alfons schuhbeck stört die maske nicht
dagegen die angst der händler mehr
gesundheitsschutz bedeutet für sie
weniger kunden und weniger umsatz
jetzt soll jetzt eigentlich seit zwei
wochen dass man das mal positive zahlen
schreiben da ist mal wieder aufgehen
wird können heute die nächste sammlung
freier natur schauen sie an alzheimer
und motor ist nichts los ist an conny
land und die leute heute mehr abstand
warum muss ich doch noch mal einen
draufsetzen dann muss ich doch da
hingehen und sagen okay dann muss ich da
bin
es sind solche szenen aus den
vergangenen wochen mit denen sich viele
münchner die gestiegenen
infektionszahlen erklären
die stadt hat deshalb an wochenenden ein
alkoholverbot an zentralen plätzen
verhängt wegen corona fällt das
oktoberfest aus doch die wirte haben
sich etwas anderes ausgedacht die
wirtshaus wiesen und die steht unter
beobachtung
wir werden sehr rigoros kontrollieren
dass die regeln eingehalten werden denn
bilder die durch die welt gehen wo wir
menschen auf den bänken stehen und sich
zuprosten ohne abstand ohne maske die
will ich nicht sehen und die wird auch
noch einmal geben doch der appell des
oberbürgermeisters zur mäßigung
verhallte in so manchen das städten
ich freue mich sehr hier zu sein heute
abend den haben ich finde haben wir so
ein ort
das war's schon comedy im krone hotspot
freitagabend hessel broker probt für
ihren auftritt in haben für die
veranstalter in der maximilian halle ist
es der erste seit monaten ein wagnis
unter verschärften bedingungen nur ein
drittel der plätze darf belegt werden
den ganzen abend herrscht strenge masken
pflicht also die schutzkonzepte scheinen
gut aus checkt zu sein oder ausgeklügelt
wenn man ein schlaues vorher benutzen
will
also ich habe auch das gefühl die leute
brauchen zwar so ein bisschen um
reinzukommen und zu merken na ja wir
sind jetzt wieder nicht zu hause am
fernsehen schauen ohne unterhose sondern
wirklich unter leuten die uns auch
werden dafür waren wir lachen aber das
funktioniert eigentlich sehr gut ein
paar hundert meter weiter trainiert der
asv hamm-westfalen für den saison start
der profis am kommenden samstag war
alles vorbereitet an hygiene konzept für
950 fans wegen des corona ausbruchs wird
daraus nichts
und was haben sie gedacht als sie gehört
haben so wegen so ein paar hochzeiten
spielte es wieder ohne publikum gefreut
haben wir uns nicht darüber und
diplomatisch auszudrücken
klar er wenn man die nachricht dann
kriegt man natürlich erstmal ein
bisschen geplättet und dementsprechend
geht der ganze apparat los alle
sponsoren zu informieren die ordner
sicherheitsdienst die fans die cpp dass
man den erst mal wieder sagt es geht
noch nie es geht zwar spoerli los aber
ihr seid noch nicht dabei schon wieder
abwarten der verlust für den verein geht
bei jedem spieltag ohne fans
die zehntausende
[Musik]
in münchen im hofbräukeller darf nicht
zu viel stimmung aufkommen kein tanzen
auf bänken oder im gang und vor allem
ein mitsing verbot der kapellmeister hat
deshalb alle wiesn hits von helene
fischer aus dem report wahrgenommen
hätten uns natürlich total bank sie
können auch mit bayerische uhr exista
blasmusik lustig sein und feiern aber
schön getrennt an einem tisch dürfen
maximal fünf personen sitzen oder zwei
haushalte diese wunderschönen abtrennen
die haben wir dann noch kurzfristig
gekauft also ich bin sogar selbst
geschnellt und her gefahren und habe mir
was einfallen lassen es an gegenständen
anstoßen mit plastikfolie dazwischen und
zwar nicht ob es wirklich etwas bringt
aber besser als nichts hilft dann hilft
sie sind zu besuch in münchen zu acht in
einer wohnung hier im wirtshaus aber
müssen sie jetzt an zwei tischen sitzen
die korona regeln beachten nicht immer
ganz einfach selber wissen ist
einzuhalten aber wenn also ein alkohol
im spiel sondern mehr trinkt wird
versucht die diesen wesen tour setzt den
wirten droht bei verstößen ein bußgeld
von mindestens 5000 euro bei privaten
feiern drinnen dürfen sie nur noch
gruppen von bis zu 25 personen zulassen
und fürchten umsatzeinbußen heute
herrlichen geburtstag mit 70 leuten
denen musste jetzt reduzieren auf 25
jetzt hoffe ich natürlich dass das dann
für den herbst wieder ein bisschen
gelockert wird
und ja wir wissen es nicht wir müssen
schauen dass wir diesen winter
geschaffen
in münchen ist die zahl der
neuinfektionen jetzt wieder gesunken
trotzdem rechnen die wirte mit einem
harten corona winter und in hamm gibt es
am sonntagabend eine schlechte und eine
gute nachricht für oberbürgermeister
hunsteger-petermann die wahl hat er
verloren aber die zahl der neu mit
corona infizierten geht auch hier
erstmals leicht zurück
[Musik]